eh bien nous voici de retour ici à
londres on verse être studio pour la
septième partie septième partie de ce
match on s'approche donc de la moitié
avec toujours un petit avantage à
vladimir kramnik qui a gagné la seconde
ici donc les joueurs ne vont pas tarder
puisque dans quelques minutes ils vont
nous rejoindre sur scène kasparov a
encore souffert mardi avec les pièces
noires pour l'instant à chaque fois
qu'il a eu les noirs kasparov a toujours
été en grande difficulté il a perdu une
partie est à chaque fois dans les deux
autres il a perdu un pion mais a réussi
à tenir grâce à ses talents incroyables
de défenseur et de fighters kasparov qui
pour l'instant évite de sombrer dans ce
match est la question qui va se poser
aujourd'hui maintenant que kasparov a
les blancs c est ce qu il va revenir à
la l'ouverture avec le pion du roi et
affronter une nouvelle fois la
berlinoise de chroniques ou est-ce qu'il
ya définitivement abandonné cette option
et va-t-il jouer comme dimanche dernier
ses quatre premiers coups qui à dimanche
dernier qui a ouvert la partie donc
question aujourd'hui est ce que kasparov
a préparé depuis la semaine dernière une
nouveauté ou un plan qui va permettre de
mettre kramnik en difficulté sur la
défense berlinoise
voilà la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui avec kasparov qui a les
pièces blanches
la tension va être très forte
aujourd'hui comme le week-end prochain
les deux joueurs jouent deux parties
d'affilée kramnik ayant les blancs
samedi
si le scénario de la semaine prochaine
de semaine dernière se répète kramnik va
épuiser kasparov samedi et samedi et de
dimanche kasparov ne peut plus lutter
avec les blancs il est trop fatigué et
ça ça a l'air d'être un petit avantage
pour chronique il peut profiter de ce
petit cette petite asymétrie dans le
match le week-end seul jour au cramique
peut jouer avec les blancs le samedi et
kasparov doit répondre dès le lendemain
avec les blancs et donc subir la fatigue
de la veille
puisqu'on sait que pour attaquer en
général il faut un peu plus d'énergie
que pour défendre
et la chronique pour l'instant en très
bonne posture mais le match peut
basculer à tout moment
on a vu comment kasparov arrive à sauver
des positions qui semblent désespérés
c'est un magicien ce kasparov il ne faut
jamais oublier qu'il est capable de
sortir un coup extraordinaire
kasparov champion du monde depuis 15 ans
donc on est en attente maintenant de
raymond tine qui va présenter présenter
ce match et dans ce cas là on lui
passera le micro pour que vous puissiez
entendre ces commentaires en anglais
juste avant l'arrivée des joueurs
mardi dernier la partie la plus longue
du match plus de six heures et demie de
jeu partie extraordinaire peut-être la
plus belle du match une des plus belles
parties de championnat du monde qu'on
ait jamais vu
fantastique cramique qui trouve un coup
incroyable cavale et ses 17 cas est l'un
des sept qui s'infiltrent d'un camp noir
et qui maintiennent équilibre alors
qu'on pensait que les noirs allaient
reprendre l'avantagé sur cette partie et
puis le plan superbe de cramique qui
infiltrent ces deux tours sa tour et
saddam dans le camp adverse menaçant le
roi de kasparov d'un math imminent et le
king qui se sort d'extrême justesse de
ce mauvais pas très très belle partie un
rebondissement
et on a eu l'impression que kasparov
allait reprendre l'initiative dans le
match avec les pièces noires et ça c'est
peut-être un signe peut-être on va
retrouver un kasparov conquérant
aujourd'hui va-t-il enfin réussir à
déborder kramnik voilà vraiment clean
qui prend le micro
arbitre polonais vient de lui donner et
il va présenter
voilà alors il faut qu'il ait d'abord
qui pousse le bouton home voilà sa
lettre à lui alors je ne sais pas au
niveau du son par aulas est monté d'un
défaut nous soutenons
il arrivera dans les bacs et aux rêves
et cette crise
la carcasse port
here is
oui on pensait qu'il avait joué ses 4
dimanche parce qu'il était fatigué qui
voulait faire mieux le rapide et
peut-être revenir quatre plus tard et
non et pour l'instant ils reviennent
toujours pas de cap mais à tout moment
il peut revenir 4 et la chronique se
posera la question est-ce qu'il a
préparé quelque chose et cramique répète
répète la même ouverture que dimanche
dernier une partie qui s'était terminée
par une nulle relativement rapide là on
a beaucoup de pression aujourd'hui
beaucoup de pression notamment de
technique puisque aujourd'hui c'est un
jour spécial puisque sur internet vous
pouvez suivre le match soit en rial
player soit théoriquement en windows
media vous pouvez éventuellement vous
connecter sur l'interface anglaise et
sur l'interface anglaise vous avez la
possibilité de voir le match soit en
réel player soit en windows media
effectivement du beau monde
et là c'est parti
cavalli f6 alors mis à jouer
différemment là ça jouer un peu
différemment je sais plus par rapport à
la partie de dimanche
on va voir tout de suite la position est
un peu pris de court ce qu'on peut
vendre l'échiquier réel peut être
rapidement
siki réel voilà bravo la réalisation
donc c4 c5 cavaliers f3 4,6 des quatre
pions prend des quatre cavaliers prendre
les 4 et le coup à six je pense qu'on a
dévié déjà de la partie de dimanche
dernier
oui il avait joué j'ai trois c'est ça
n'avait joué j'ai trois donc là ça y est
là c'est lui qui prend tout de suite
initiative au centre parce qu'il avait
laissé cramique réagir par des cinq ans
joint g3 et sas avait laissé
l'initiative à kramnik la kasparov a
compris que s'il veut déstabiliser
kramnik il va falloir qui s'occupe un
peu plus hardiment du centre sinon ils
aiment pas ils n'aiment pas rester à
table
l'un en face de l'autre il évite de se
regarder oui on peut imaginer joueurs
qu'il sortirait un ordinateur de poche
est ce que maintenant ils sont très
forts les ordinateurs de poche ils
peuvent voir en tout cas des variantes
simple away en récepteurs qui serait
connecté connecter un ordinateur de la
nasa piraté par la mafia russe sur
lesquelles il aurait installé et pierre
cros et sur lequel il aurait installé
donc un gros un gros mot ordinateur de
calcul pour calculer les variantes
on peut alors pourquoi pierre cros
pierre cros qu'on salue ici un à londres
pierre ocre aux nôtres techniciens de
choc à canal web grâce auquel on a une
régie numérique capable d'envoyer des
flux réels player et windows media
instantanément à 6 milliards de
personnes
et oui c'est pierre pierre cros pierre
cros le magicien du windows media et là
c'est kasparov le magicien de
l'échiquier qui s'est sorti en fait il a
fait comme on dit ni on a bien en revue
les images au ralenti il a fait comme on
dit ni comme on l'avait dit si le au
dîner des échecs kasparov puisque il
était vraiment la tête sous l'eau
cadenassé dans un cercueil qui étaient
cloués et enroulé d'une corde bien
solidement attachés et qu'elles sauront
s'en est sorti ce qui est quand même
assez assez revoir c'est le roi de
l'évasion
c'est pour ça que ce paraphe réfléchir
c'est incroyable chroniques postées à
chaque fois cram nick ne veut pas que
kasparov déroule sa préparation
il est prêt à jouer des coups peut-être
même un peu inférieur mais qui
surprennent kasparov et qu'il oblige à
réfléchir dès le début kasparov ne peut
pas dominer cram ni dans sa préparation
il doit jouer aux échecs on peut pas
montrer l'échiquier de démonstration
si on doit pouvoir le faire et bien il
semblerait qu'il se passe c'est ce qu'on
peut pas vérifier ce qui se passe à l'as
réal là pourquoi on n'a pas les chics et
de démonstration ça c'est curieux quand
même alors montrons l'échiquier réel
avec qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien il
ya plus de réel voilà il n'ya plus de
qu'est-ce qui se passe
est ce qu'on voudrait qu'on peut bien
donner des informations pourquoi on ne
peut pas voir l'échiquier à voilà ça y
est voilà chéquier de démonstration si
on peut raccourcir un peu l'image en bas
voila voila c'est bon donc là nous avons
le dernier coup de crâne x au cou à
cette a6 très surprenant normalement on
dit toujours qu'il ne faut pas faire ce
qu'on appelle les oreilles d'âne c'est à
dire les coûts à cette a6 et acheta
fasciste et phone oui alors pourtant
enfin si ça se joue comme dans
l'espagnol dans la sicilienne aussi ça
se joue souvent fait à 6 h 6 peut-être
un peu moins haut que kasparov encore
embêter donc ici telle est l'idée
qu'elle est l'idée est ce que ce que sur
ce plan on pourrait être cadré kasparov
un peu plus à droite
garry kasparov moi ici peut jouer qu'à
laisser trop à stéphane effectivement
suivi éventuellement de e24 et on
arrivera dans une sorte dé toute ma roxy
alors on peut peut-être détaillé on va
montrer une variante assas en panne
sorte centre est complètement ailleurs
c'est une variante possible qu'à laisser
3 il pourrait suivre par exemple il
suivrait des cinq chroniques a prévu des
cinq camps étaient prévus des salariés
sur kramnik veut jouer pour le centre
tout de suite il a démontré plusieurs
fois crânement jouer des cinq boîtes
supposons cravic joue aussi ce qu'il
paraît plus raisonnable oui
ici quel sport jour et aux 4 et après un
petit coup comme 17 des six et bien
c'est un pur et audemars auxi on sait
que les blancs ont l'avantagé se passe
mais c'est très difficile à gagner tout
à fait blanc entend davantage parce
qu'ils ont deux pions là qui contrôle
très très bien le centre alors que
la parole en réflexion dès le 4e ou
encore une fois et oui ça devient
tellement usuels que ce n'est plus
surprenant c'est plus sûr moyen de
bulles début de ce match
kasparov ne peut pas réciter sa
préparation c'est impossible cramique a
prévu plein de variantes secondaire
réputé comme peut-être moins un pointu
qui mais qui en pratique ne sont pas
prévus dans le répertoire de kasparov
parce que justement réputés moins forte
et donc du coup il ne peut pas réciter
sa préparation le petit gars y est
obligé de réfléchir par lui même lorsqu
on peut leur montrer la position et loi
pour l'instant c'est parce qu'ils
étaient joué du tout puisque là on en
est qu'au quatrième coup alors que là on
montre une variante possible
voilà voilà la position réelle sur
l'échiquier cramique a joué le coup
petit coup à cette astuce le petit coup
de pied haut à gauche
et ce petit coup de pions pose aucun
problème
kasparov c'est un coût qui a vite
kasparov a joué des variantes qui n'a
peut-être pas l'habitude de jouer ça
coûte surprenant 1,6 normalement jouer
du helmand le coup eux c est aussi ça la
place qui est plus naturelle puisque
l'idée vraisemblable doit cesser de
jouer bessengue stéphane mais ici ça
mais très influent prise quand même oui
oui et non je suis peut-être aussi dans
vos mails devraient empêcher un cavalier
de venir sur la classe b 5 puisque la
case windows 7 et 21 des six pourront
s'avérer faible quand les noirs orange
l'union du roi
c'est vrai on a envie de mettre la dame
sur cette cadence et 7 ces sacs est
naturel voilà c'est maintenant on peut
le faire
d'un autre côté on n'est en général pas
pressé de jouer ce coup à cette façon le
décale ont tout d'abord aussi nice on
joue d'abord fawcett on oui mais
d'autres coups c'est une surprise quand
même à 7 festif activement situe
surprise et encore une fois c'est très
bien joué de la part de crâne qui
surprend kasparov entraîné un jeu je ne
sais pas bien mais au moins il me
surprend c'est que d'autres déjà ça de
gagné parce que sur ce plan d'image de
kasparov ne pourrait pas le cas les un
peu plus à droite si c'est possible
là ça permettrait de mieux cerner ses
ducasse a en fait bien quand même bien
aplati sur l'échiquier et ça c'est quand
même joli plan d'un kasparov aplati
tapis tapis prêt à bondir
voilà le kasparov le kasparov dans les
fourrés prêt à bondir sur sa proie
à noter quand même que kasparov
souffrent dans les ouvertures en tout
cas c'est toujours lui le premier avec
les chiens ici bon effectivement sa
position comme meilleur le cou à cette
a6 ne peut pas être une réputation du
système adopté par heymans et pas
d'invitation c'est encore une fois un un
petit coup de pic de chroniques hop un
petit coup non prévus et à toi de jouer
vas-y enfin il n'y a aucun doute dans
les coûts à venir kasparov va prendre un
petit avantage
c'est hautement probable il était il est
en train de regarder les différentes
possibilités
ne nous emballons pas ce n'est pas parce
qu'il réfléchit qu'il est déjà dans
leurs beaux m on n'est pas dans la boîte
du tout il n'a pas de problème pour
l'instant garry kasparov il cherche le
meilleur moyen de continuer cette partie
après 1,6 il a beaucoup de solutions
peugeot avec g3 il peut jouer qu'à
laisser trois un étonnant roxy il peut
également envisager d'autres
possibilités c'est ce qu'il fait en ce
moment peut jouer peut-être fou je ne
sais pas danser la vc3 voilà il très
normal car sport très normal que les c3
puisqu'il est en général ce sont les
cavaliers avant les foules puisque les
cavaliers dans des cases naturel alors
que les fous c'est moins clair mais
plusieurs classes de leur disposition 20
à 30 kg unique pas de bluff pas mal se
couvre alors aussi c'est pas mal parce
que en cas de 2,4 il peut y avoir le
coup en mettant enfin toujours un petit
peu
surprenant mais embêtant food et 4 on va
montrer peut-être cette possibilité oui
alors je ne crois pas que ce soit l'idée
mais oui mais ça peut ce que j'ai déjà
vu des partis comme ça je crois que
c'est peter l'écho le spécialiste alors
on va voir ça tout de suite chic et
voilà alors vraisemblablement le coût
attendu par kasparov ce2 leucate et la
sorbonne comme un petit point une
technique alors à près de 4 et bien non
pas de problème technique stéphane tout
va bien tout va pour le mieux
ici nous attendons qu'on monte non là
c'est très bien c'est très bien quoi le
problème
il n'y a pas de problème en fait
simplement le couple de 2,4 va-t-il
d'être jouée par kasparov mais là la
lordose classe aa non et non et non et
non et oui oui 3 et là est ce que
kramnik peut continuer par des 5
c'est un peu dans l'idée de ce qu'ils
avaient fait dimanche c'est une question
ça me rappelle une partie de garry
kasparov et une grande partie du cast
art of dance s est donc ramené 7 est
décidé à jouer ils jouent les taux de
maroc si avec g3 alors ce n'est pas tout
à fait un étonnement aussi c'est plutôt
une anglaise stéphane mais ça ressemble
à une partie de la cascade contre nigel
short ici dams et 7 ce n'est pas un
choix anodin ça attaque directement
pioncer 4 oui oui et puis c'est pas moi
c'est juste élu s'est joué contre g3 au
muy tranquille crabe dit qu'ils allaient
à hyper serein ses fans à leur attention
mais c'est un peu trop tôt pour tirer
des conclusions évidemment les deux
joueurs connaissent cette position oui
mais en impression de chroniques
il a l'air plus rien de kasparov quand
même il essaie de se rappeler il ya une
maintenance c'est de se rappeler il fait
des tentatives de puiser dans sa mémoire
prodigieuse déjà garry kasparov tête
dans les mains
tatata vraiment ça alors que krainik en
phase doit être un homme il alerte et
autres cool kramnik et l'échangé de
costard en plus il a changé de costard
en train d'être admis qu'il est tout en
noir alors on va montrer un vraiment
très l'échiquier de démonstration voilà
ça y est notre à elle a commencé à
prendre le rythme donc là on choisit
pays kasparov attaque alors qu'à ce
moment alors si c'est bien et c'est pas
mal ce qui s'avère très précis et loi
puisque l'idée des blats ans était de
jouer et après j'ai trois fous g2 et se
fout du coup ça enlève de la diagonale
oui contrôler le pion c4 donc ça pose un
problème blanc commandé fin de ce pion
puisque si maintenant on joue aux 2 3 on
affaiblit terriblement les cases
blanches dans une situation de joueurs
peuvent de 3 il va jouer sans doute soit
dame b3 qui est un coup qu'on n'a pas
envie de jouer dans le détroit on n'a
pas envie de jouer non plus un b3 à b2
b3 on n'a pas envie non plus les fans et
aussi sa problème c'est que l'on n'a pas
envie de jouer parce que sur b3 il ya un
problème direct stéphane a besoin qu'on
peut jouer le coup de 17 des 58 f b 4
aussi il est celle des 5 ça a l'air à
wade était pourtant à whistler
directement l'initiative parce que les
cils et blanc prennent en d5 le cas au
lycée trois survient prise de la dame
est oui alors là là là donc ici comment
garder l'espoir veut-il défendre
l'option c'est archi connu ça et la
question va t'il de défendre puisque je
crois me rappeler dans sa part
compromettre sacrifié depuis ont-ils ne
l'avait pas défendu ah oui mais alors
c'est donc peut-être une préparation de
chroniques sur la base de la partie de
kasparov contre short
alors honnêtement je ne me rappelle plus
très bien de l'ordre de coût de cette
partie qui espère en short ou mais ça y
ressemble on ne va pas dans notre base
on avait un an ne l'a pas dans la base
malheureusement puisque la base n'a pas
été mise à jour depuis quelques années
et on pourrait peut-être vérifier sur
son internet très loin oui on pointe a
fait sur internet bien sûr mais on ne va
pas le faire puisque c'est quand même
assez compliqué c'est vrai ça mange de
la bande passante stéphane lapointe le
programme très peu un peu trop en tout
cas très peu un pourri ans pour une fois
pas voilà on pourrait frappe à ta tion
n'a pas envie de savoir
on n'a pas envie de savoir et vous
ordonne que ce soit la surprise voilà et
puis on n'a pas envie de rentrer dans
les débats théoriques est ce que cette
partie était jouée ou pas ou qu'est ce
que c'est
ça c'est la sphère des professionnels
nous ont fait des commentaires pour que
vous appréciez le jeu d'échecs
on va pas vous assommer avec des
vieilles partie des rares hausses
variant trop technique c'est pas le but
plus tôt vous dire que la question fait
en train de se craqueler les oreilles et
que c'est mauvais signe
aulas le cas sparrow en direct d'un
petit sourire
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire en
général ce que ça peut vouloir dire
c'est une petite merde je comprends pas
comment j'ai pu faire une gaffe pareil
on va prédominer dans médias
non mais comment j'ai pu blesser a mené
sur une préparation de chronique est ce
possible
on a vu que kasparov faisait souvent
cette tête là et qu'en fait au final il
était mieux quand il était mieux quand
même donc il faut faire bien fait c'est
pas parce qu'il fait la tête façon c'est
clair on ne peut pas être moins bien sur
cette position
c'est pas possible maintenant la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
est-ce que kasparov va continuer sur ce
rythme puisqu'il a déjà utilisé un quart
d'heure de temps contre 2 minutes à
chronique une minute trente à cramique
exactement contre un quart d'heure à
kasparov et ça c'est important ça c'est
très important parce que s'ils
continuent réfléchir ainsi kasparov
alors que kramnik lui a l'air en nous en
nos connu alors plus qu'à soi on va
peut-être
à se poser des questions est ce que
kramnik à préparer quelque chose sur la
partie que j'avais joué contre shore qui
ressemble beaucoup à celle là et dans ce
cas-là cranie va gagner du temps - dans
cette partie et il va peut-être sortir
un coup qui améliorent la partie de
short c'est très probable d'ailleurs
quel sport dans cette partie et c'est
connu c'est très connu il était mal donc
est vrai à mon avis tu y as partners n'a
pas envie de réitérer cette partie mais
ici elles sont ce n'est pas la position
ne peut pas en être sûr en tout cas bien
exporter la tête nous fait vraiment la
tête à stéphane c'est quand même c'est
tout à fait un bien fou
il a les deux yeux fermés il est dans
les cordes
déjà après six coups avec les blancs il
ne s'est apparemment plus quoi faire
ou alors il cache bien son jeu et garry
kasparov en tout cas le ku'damm sessad
de chroniques le dernier coup qu'il a
joué à l'air très très ennuyeux pour le
champion c'est un gros problème parce
que si l'histoire ne sait plus quoi
jouer sur quatre et plus donc plus qu'à
jouer sur ces quatre caisses qui a joué
et bien leur en ai joué detroit ou
peut-être bep cap ou à trois ou à croire
en tout cas ce prof avec les noirs à des
problèmes et donc s'ils n'arrivent pas à
poser des justement d'apprendre ma
chronique avec et blanc est bien une
vague est parti pour souffrir puisque on
a vu que les trois parties kasparov
avait les noirs et bien il était raide
trois fois son est sorti deux fois
m'ont dit vous dit pour l'instant guinea
mais à force de clouer le cercueil de le
mettre à six pieds sous terre et
peut-être pas trouvé à chaque fois une
tunnel de sortie
c'est à dire que oui oui tout à fait
vrai ses chroniques qui fixe les
conditions de l'enfermement et si
krainik arrive à trouver quelque chose
est bien ou dites moi ne pourra plus
s'en sortir
effectivement garry kasparov là est un
peu surprenant aujourd'hui puisque après
six coups avec et blanc il est déjà en
train de réfléchir
qu'at-il vue alors attention
rassemblement les blancs sont encore un
petit peu mieux mais ils ont un problème
concret à résoudre c'est la défense de
se fiancer 4 on ne sait pas trop comment
ils vont faire ça n'a pas l'air
complètement facile c'est vraiment très
intéressant qui se passe alors que
stéphane laborde est en train de tourner
dans le détroit
quelle horreur quelle horreur stéphane
c'est un coup absolument infos-eau
ku'damm détroit quand c'est un joli coup
c'est horrible pourquoi elle vient parce
que la dame en d3 est tout simplement
très très mal placée ou pour envisager
pour pratiquer si on peut voir lâcheté
de démonstration on peut envisager le
coup d'essai de l'es6 suivi de cavale et
b17 et le chaos ni pour aller quand même
mis en réseau local prend ainsi soin
depuis pas mal aussi mp et c6 à ce qu'a
laissé six reines d'ascq avait dit au
centre sa menace calais au sein qui
gagne un pion aulas ou autres kasparov
tête à quel point ces 600 obligé au lab
et ça c'est pas l'air bon non c'est pas
bon ça celle de central la lumière alors
attention il faut prendre du plomb du ou
des pions c'est la mission des
réductions bébés stéphane gerber pardon
en générant le dit plutôt du pion b on
est vraiment très chic et démonstrations
là il faut que kramnik prennent en
général du pion le pion b puisque ça
ramène un pion au centre et ça va
permettre au noir joué le coup 17 des 5
avec une grande force
sauf s'il blanc joue à 4 tout à fait
donc ici c'est au choix
c'est un choix à faire pour vladimir
kramnik ses com
déjà une concession des blancs
personnellement je prendrais plutôt du
pion des pions baies du monde et pour
aller vers le centre ça permet ensuite
de jouer ces cinq justice projet c'est
par exemple les plans 2d surprend des
pionniers le problème c'est que
effectivement bon le fou si vite peut
pas sortir tout de suite et puis et puis
les classements rend l'air faible du
côté dames
si on prend une option d'essai pour
égaliser tout simplement c'est
simplement on mettra la structure tout à
fait symétrique on peut l'envisager ici
si on prend ça fait une structure
d'options symétrique trois contre trois
à gauche 4 car il va prendre une à
prendre du plomb il a et érigeant des
ceux qui ont des îles appris que tu en
délit chronique surprenant c'est assez
surprenant on dit plutôt un les
noyellois il faut prendre du plomb b
pourquoi il prend du plomb des quotas
doivent côté on voit que le foot
kasparov qui va vraisemblablement elle
et angers 2 ne sera pas bien passé
puisque il tapera contre un mur de pions
et tu obéis c'est quand ils veulent
changer de camp même ne peut pas jouer
autre chose il va je faisais de y
kasparov
est-ce que kramnik problèmes'' gbwa
escoulen déprendre remarquer l'inversé
il a l'air très tranquille vladimir
kramnik et kasparov bon n'a pas l'air
convaincu mais pas du tout histoire une
possibilité les noirs seraient déjà
mieux
non non
possibilité qu'ils en parlent à
l'absurde les normes sont pas mieux mais
ils ont peut-être déjà égalisé ça c'est
possible mais ça alors il faut quand
même expliqué déjà que au début mais les
blancs sont mieux stéphane parce que
c'est nous qui commence mes parties oui
mais en général s'il exerce sa fonction
quelque part est là le problème c'est
que là les pièces noires sont sortis le
cas les six est sorti le fouet fuite va
pas trop avoir de mal et le pouce et 8
ont tous supposés qui va sortir
comment il voit la csn a joué 5 square
ne va pas le sortir puisque on peut
considérer ce fou que m très développé
oui mais sur le sort pas ce fou comme on
sort la tour 1 8 oui alors bon ça c'est
c'est un débat très active dans la série
de ça le problème des noirs pour
l'instant le seul petit défaut dans la
position noir c'est ce fou c'est vide
qui sort pas et éventuellement les pions
les cases noires du côté dames
si on peut les montrer ses cases noires
qui sont peut-être un tout petit peu oui
enfin on peut les montrer mais bon c'est
pas c'est un affadissement puisque
contre vous ont ajouté 17 on a le fou
qui est là qui les contrôlent ces cases
noires ne sont absolument pas faible
donc alors le petit premier noir se fout
si vite n'en reste que le fou s'évitant
problème mais à l'internât les noirs
peuvent le plein couple veut jouer avec
eux 6 e 5 c'est une possibilité
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que le foot
garry kasparov se fout là une fois
qu'ils se rangeaient 2 sera complètement
inactif tout simplement ne sera pas bien
placé alors qu'il faudra mener que
peuvent trouver des postes très
intéressant par exemple après e5 est fou
aussi c'est une malle casse pour le fou
ou alors se sentir seule fois mais le
cul en scène connaissent pas d'être
faibles n'ont pas trop non non je pense
maintenant je pense qu'il a une belle
position la ligne de tram mais qui peut
aussi replacer le caddie m6 chronique
doit jouer pour le ghana cette partie je
pense que va simplement chronique à une
stratégie qui est loin d'être mauvaise
c'est de neutraliser avec les noirs et
des sets gagnés avec les blancs 6 ha non
mais ça c'est le rêve absolu si on
arrive à faire ça et lois en général
c'est que c'est qu'on est très fort oui
le fait est que chronique est très fort
ouais ok on va chercher il n'y a rien ça
y est nul nul indique ou peut-être
aujourd'hui parce qu'on va jouer ou g2
proposé nul mais là ça serait une grosse
grosse concession
surtout quand on y va refuser
ça lui mettrait un coup au moral à garry
kasparov mais dans ces spéculations il
joue fou j'ai deux balles de set est
clair convaincus ou g2 et il se lève pas
qu est-ce qu on ne se lève pas il sait
que kramnik connaît cette position et
c'est que kramnik va jouer vite mais pas
trop doute kramnik à la chronique grave
ni ça se joue impressionné le 5-5 il
sait ce qu'il fait m'a dit rien des
clients c'est sûr que kramnik et
essayent alors là les noirs n'ont plus
aucun problème de développement et loi
leur faut en sortir sur des jolies case
le fou ces huit sur la case au cices
menace a au passage tour des huit
probablement gagné en deux temps sur la
dame c'est le plan et le faut et fuite
va sortir sur sept soit ans et 5 soit en
b 4 il semblerait que cram dic soit mort
de rire dans cette position peut revenir
presque téléphone le 6 ou subissent un
retour des 8 qui attaquera la dame
depuis cette case très important ça tu
gagneras du temps ensuite fawcett est
petit rock c'est très simple et là il y
avait rien là simple et noir en tout
simplement résolu tous leurs produits
l'ouverture l'admirent chronique à moi
engagement aucun défaut puisque on voit
mal comment cas ce qu'on pourrait
profiter de l'affaiblissement des cases
noires à gauche
non mais il n'y a pas de feu glissement
à gauche mais il s'assure qu'il ya joué
caritas partie les cheveux petit rock et
on peut pas imaginer un plan pour
kasparov avec à base de fouet trois
cavaliers à 4 on peut l'imaginer
on peut l'imaginer mais parce qu'ils
jouaient h trois classes par an cela il
jouait h3 avec l'idée de jouer trouvé
trois mois est de toute façon surtout au
6e tour des huit déjà directement en
chasse la dame ensuite on peut jouer 15
et 17
il n'y a pas de problème pour venir cram
dit qu'ici c'est très très tranquille
d'un point de vue philosophique il aux
structures de pions légèrement meilleur
avec les noirs car plus compact et plus
solides le fou g2 est mal placée d'un
point de vue
philosophique vont être cramique serait
donc un philosophe
ça c'est la nouvelle du jour cramique le
nouveau le nouveau spinoza la
philosophie de la structure de pions un
peu comme fille dort philidor le grand
joueur d'échecs des xviiie siècle qui
avaient dit les pions sont l'âme du jeu
d'échecs un petit peu peu très peu de
temps avant la révolution française qui
allait lui donner raison
tout à fait quelque sorte oui ces termes
ont clairement on voit très bien le
rapprochement
ainsi donc spinoza être fille dort
contre les frères karamazov beau match
alors là c'est marrant parce que kramnik
kramnik a gardé son complet noir et
kasparov a enlevé son veston lui donc il
est quasiment finie claire kasparov
s'est cependant fait dénudée dans sicko
dr ils allaient blanc alors que cramique
est plutôt sombre est allé noir au
niveau visuel sacré
il a joué kasparov qu'est ce qu'elle est
je vais petit revenu sur les sujets
qu'ils soient si petites réflexions vos
chroniques
c'est à dire qu'il a du mal à y croire
chronique il se dit je ne comprends pas
attention aux menaces tour des huit
gagnants et loi parce que la dame ne
peut plus protéger le cas on va montrer
ça tout de suite un menaces de cramique
ça y est c chronique qui menace le
premier avec les noirs ça c'est
incroyable
la menace c'est imaginons que les noirs
et les blancs jouent à coup par exemple
à trois imaginée lequel un jeune couple
dont par exemple a-2 a-3 à a-2 a-3
laminoir j'aurai le coup tours en des
huit attaquants la dame et la dame ne
peut plus protéger le pion c4 par
exemple surnomment ses 2 et bien il y
avoue penser quatre voies la série
gagnante y ont gagné un pur net c'est la
menace ici menace de chroniques que ma
frappe kasparov detroit mais b3 à l'air
hamissi b36 bien sûr puisque b3 à l'idée
de 14,6 probablement de mettre le fou
sur la case b2 et de d'attaquer le pion
au 5 mai 3 c'est une possibilité mais
après tour des huit
on ne voit pas ce qui peut inquiéter
manière chronique ici dams et 2 bonjour
tranquillement fosse est un peu tiré 2 2
ouais mais y'a petit robe toute façon
stéphane la dame c'est cette défense
numéro 5
y'a pas de problème pour les noirs ils
ont sorti toutes leurs pièces ils vont
échanger les tours et légères avantage
noir dans cette finale a priori
voilà donc nous revenir veiller à 4
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer cavalier à
quatre dames on peut jouer stéphane mais
ça n'a pas d'idées alors s'il faut trois
mêmes il accueille 17 / photo ce n'est
pas une vraie menace et khaled et celle
du coup qu'elle est dans une position
passive peut-être ouais m'enfin lequel
délicate aussi les biens peuvent jouer 2
4 non là on s'égare complètement
il faut revenir on va revenir la
position c'est celle de la cause ijaw
six mois la voilà kramnik vient de jouer
tout aussi ce qu'on peut montrer la
position là juste pour rappeler
voilà voilà la position réelle actuelle
la menace de kramnik c'est de jouer la
torah 80 des huit attaquants la dame et
le fou va gober le pion c4 puisque la
dame ne pourra pas sortir de la taille
de la tour est protégée de pioncer 4 il
n'y a pas de case possible et ça c'est
un petit ennui et lala kasparov c'est
sûr lillois sait sur quel sens de cette
position n'a quasiment aucun avantage
bon alors mais tu n'as pas davantage du
tout à noter crâne joueur indique ou via
de neutraliser kasparov avec une
facilité déconcertante la fête kasparov
a eu peur de jouer la variante qui
laisse le pion ces cartes remplies
oui je sais pas si elle existe cette
variante en fait je ne suis pas
complètement sûr ça paraissait douteux
déception ces quatre reprises cramique
extrêmement bien préparés pour ce match
et ça c'est la première fois que
kasparov
je vous comprend un joueur en match de
championnat du monde qui ait autant de
facilité à le désarçonner dans les
ouvertures granik a extrêmement bien
préparés psychologiquement ces
ouvertures
c'est clair il n'a pas cherché les
meilleurs d'ouverture mais celles qui
vont qui pose le plus de problème
kasparov et ça s'est finalement joué un
petit peu à la sq r on va dire est loin
la sq est requis ce grand champion
allemand champion du monde pendant 20
ans qui est un ami de albert einstein et
qui préconisait aux échecs la
psychologie plutôt que la précision
il disait il valait mieux jouer le coup
qui embête le plus d'adversaires que
jouer forcément le meilleur coup il a
dit à ce sujet des débats passionnés
vous avez d'ailleurs à ce sujet
développement s'agit avec un style qui
était partisan plutôt de la science dure
et donc disais mais non il faut trouver
le meilleur coup je pense aux échecs
même si je taille n'était pas évidemment
du niveau de l'ass caire aux échecs mais
il y avait comme une certaine certains
arguments certains arguments qui valait
qui valaient leur pesant d'or
l'état n'était pas d'accord cette
conception de la sq air et mélasse caire
lui était champion du monde d'échecs et
son règne a duré vingt ans et le plus
long règne du jeu d'échecs
ici celui de kasparov à s'arrêter dans
deux semaines celui de questions on va
s'arrêter peut-être dans deux semaines
non c'est pas sûr cela n'est sûr mais
est ce une casserole et déjà de 15 ans
ce qui est énorme
ce qui est déjà énorme puisque ensuite
qui on va trouver lascars en premier
ensuite kasparov en terme de durée car
notre karpov qui est dû à 10 ans non
mais c'est dix ans ce n'est pas énorme
et peut-être capable au canon bobigny
guazzini qui évidemment n'a rien
d'unique et vise une interruption
oui les dessins top 100 mais bon ouais
non mais il n'a presque pas d'affilée
votre vie ni qu'il a duré longtemps mais
c'est pas d'affilée et puis si je me
saoule email été championne du monde en
48 et petrossian été champion du monde
dans 60 2 donc en fait ça ne fait ça ne
gagne ça ne laisse que
que huit ans à votre unique même sans
compter les épisodes de talent et smith
l'oeuf tout à fait stéphane et bien nous
avons docteur culture docteur histoire
s'était fait de lasbordes pour
l'histoire des échecs
il est complètement anonymes et dragons
ça fait 14 ans cette excuse moi 48 62 14
ans c'est très possible mais pas
d'affilée
ouais pas d'affilée puisque entre temps
smith l'ofs étals ont piqué un an ou
deux de règne a boat cynique bosnie que
c'est pas mal aussi mais ça reste
quatorze ans que derrière kasparov qui
sait qu'il ya d'autres à liqing aussi la
durée le local el khaliki nom du
champion du monde dans les années 30
puis elle et qui n'est mort champion du
monde monte les marches un tour du monde
pendant la guerre je crois oui c'est ça
pendant la guerre je crois qu'il aimait
donc ça aurait pu durer beaucoup plus
longtemps
alors trêve de plaisanterie kasparov ça
fait une demi heure qu'il réfléchit une
demi heure que kasparov maintenant l
erika sema enfilé il ya presqu'une
demi-heure un trou depuis le début de la
partie contre à peine cinq minutes à
kramnik et ça c'est signe que kasparov
encore une fois et désarçonnés dans
l'ouverture bon il va qu'est ce qui va s
qui ont une passion qu'on puisse y
trouve pas de plan la différence de
chroniques qui lui même quand il a une
position égale arrive à trouver des
plans d'attaqué kasparov s'il trouve pas
davantage à l'ouverture il sait plus
quoi faire
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'à ce pas
officiel et b non mais il est dominé au
milieu du hall kasparov kasparov s'en
sort très bien quand il faut calculer
quand il est encore lié d i'm not
mais quand il faut montrer une
compréhension d'enfer et bien crown il
peut toujours plus loin et ça c'est le
problème pour l'instant
pour caritas porte dans ce match ont
peut-être qu'il n'est pas chaud
puisqu'il est évidemment capable de
gagner des parties harry kasparov
on le voit chaque fois qu'il participe à
un tournoi et oui mais pas contre
chronique
il n'y a pas de gagner des parties mais
qu'entre kramnik y en a gagné que trois
sur comme une partie on tombe sur ça
fait 23 et 7 23 6 29
si on 29 parties il en allait yannick
aura donc derrière de 4 et là il reste à
jouer
il reste 10 à jouer bien jadis à jouer
c'est en effet une les sports de com de
genk ont bien de ça dont une partie est
exactement donc la casse pas encore
organisé au match mais il ne pourra pas
le gagner le match s'il continue sur le
rythme avec lequel il s'attaquera à
munich depuis le début oui vous ne le
fera pas donc remporter le match mais
légaliser ce qui lui suffit
mais si crâne qui gagne une partie c'est
fini comique une espérance de gain
supérieur d'ailleurs ce qu'il a déjà
gagné cette partie effectivement donc a
priori et cueillette bale gary kasparov
si on s'en fout si on était juste là
pour faire des mathématiques est bien
question ce ne s'en sortir d'autant plus
que si on considère le score cranie
kasparov effectivement les deux ont
gagné une partie dans les dix ce qui
reste et donc ça laissera cramique avec
un point de plus la casse ford doit
trouver quelque chose de tout à fait
extraordinaire pour s'en sortir
puisque suivant les statistiques il a
déjà perdu le match
la cote de caspar en dessin jour après
jour
et ça se voit dans le jeu ça se voit
dans le jeu en plus c'est pas vois pas
comment mac ramener qui jouent vraiment
facile granic joue trop facile avec les
noirs et arriva trop à mettre la
pression une pression incroyable avec
les blancs concernerait que la seule
chance de costaros et que kramix
enflamme le kram nick price tout
simplement parce que physiquement
rassemblant kasparov est plus fort plus
entraîné c'est aux un combat de catch le
pas de doute que ces kasparov qui
l'emportent de rien sur ce qu'il est
quand même plus grand dans milk a
travaillé plus grand mais t'es sport
c'est un centre de gravité plus bas ce
qui lui était réservé ce qui pourrait
pas justement se départager éventuelle
en cas de match nul
on pourrait proposer qui se départagent
en catch non ouais mais qui en lutte
gréco-romaine moi je te reposes non moi
je pense que l'idéal serait quand même
de faire un match où tout serait permis
tous les coups sont permis un match de
full contact qui serait quand même assez
intéressant avec cram nique et son bras
qui mesure plus d'un mètre entre
kasparov et sa petit allongé dit son jeu
de jambes très redoutable
oui j'ai mal fait mais malgré ce prof
pouvoir toucher crabe lee qui avec ses
grands bras le repoussera le touchant le
front et kasparov avec ses petits bras
et essayaient de toucher ne viendrait
pas est ce serait digne des plus grands
dessins animés mais bon kasparov et très
vive très rapide ici il peut jouer les
bons coups il peut se mettre à jour une
série beaucoup très vite
pour l'instant il a une demi heure de
retard c'est beaucoup et une position
qui n'a pas l'air de promettre grand
chose
faut bien le redire on peut vous
remonterez cette position si vous voulez
la voir
la voilà ici travnik a sorti toutes ses
pièces au programme tour d'élite un
petit coup de développement qui
attaquera la dame blanche suivis parfois
aux 7es petit rock dans la station parce
que si si les tours de 8 il est l'option
c4 est pas attachés et pas attaqué et
pas défendu pardon et bien le faux 6,20
le gober non mais l'accessoire devrait
défendre l'option sekkat a priori les
proches le contrat miksa les noirs ont
déjà l'avantagé le voyage et page
l'impression que les pièces noires sont
mieux développer notamment le faut aussi
salaires plus à la plus efficace que le
fou g2 puisqu'en cas de b3 les nord
pourront toujours jouer le coût éventuel
bessette b5 augmentant la pression sur
ses 4 et proposant un échange qui leur
ouvrirait la colonne c'est gomis qui est
ce qui est incroyable c'est que vraiment
et kasparov ne sait pas quoi faire là il
ne sait pas quoi faire ils aient dominé
ici on voit le plan de crem uniktour des
mille fois cette petit rock
toutes les pièces sont sortis la
structure de son est meilleur pour les
noirs donc a priori avantagera puisqu'il
n'y a pas de compensation pour rien et
castrophe encore un petit il ya encore
il ya encore un coût de développement de
plus non stéphane attentes mais ça sera
terminé après tour des huit cantons 10
avantages noir il faut se calmer parce
que la structure est symétrique il est
bon ou pas de faiblesse donc la médaille
d'or mais avantage voire difficile à
moyen terme de développement les normes
ont gagné en développement c'est sûr et
quand on sait la facilité aussi ou en
tout cas ce qu'a prouvé kramnik dans les
positions égal il arrive à trouver des
plants en attaque ça serait quand même
incroyable que ce soit les noirs qui met
lui blanc sous pression ça sera la
première fois du match
ces matches est noir avant de mettre les
vins sont présentés sans attention parce
que ça oui mais psychologiquement
chorale que kasparov
1 il encaisse la partie où il était
dominé mardi la partie où il sort et
éventuellement de lui dominé aujourd'hui
et samedi où cramique corps encore les
blancs c'est vrai est-ce qu'il va pas
craquer à temps à noter quand même que
hier ses grammy qui était sous pression
après d'un coup avec les blancs oui oui
en plein été sous pression psychologique
mais sur la position il a démontré qu'en
fait qu'il avait hier la chance toujours
un petit peu davantage
il a eu pas mal de chance le
pensionnaire chronique il a trouvé de
solution miracle mais il était sous
pression avec les pièces blanches
ici c'est ce qui arriva kasparov nous a
priori pas de soucis
garry kasparov ne devrait pas perdre
cette partie maintenant personne c'est
le ku'damm des trois quais quand même
très apprécié c'était fort c'est déjà
stéphane voir le coût de ces le coup
j'ai 3 alors qu'il votait le coup j'ai
trois il fallait jouer de 2,4 sa mort
est que le sixième coup des blancs g3
soit déjà une petite précision qui
permettent aux noirs d'égaliser et voire
même de prendre une petite initiative
il faut que le passeport trouve quelque
chose
faut pas aller trop vite puisqu'on a vu
on avait l'impression que kramnik aussi
avec les blancs mardi et vettel et noir
qu'elle prend des initiatives mais alala
kasparov cette expérience on ferme les
yeux qu'est ce qu'il fait qu'est-ce qui
est une ligne vers l'est ce qui serait
fatigué il est pas bien gardé de
kasparov ont en revanche cas cependant
ce sont les biens rasé il est bien rasé
et ça c'est important
mais alors faut se rappeler que le
à propos de rasage que le match de
séville 4e 27 ans kasparov était mené
1-0 par karpov
après la 23e partie est restée une
partie à jouer puisque c'était un match
en 24 et pour la dernière partie
kasparov est arrivé complètement pas
rasé du tout avec le barbe de trois
jours un air très méchant très remonté
kasparov et il a gagné la partie et ça
c'était un des plus grands moments de
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs réussir à
égaliser masse du championnat du monde à
la dernière partie c'était du jamais vu
bah surtout avec les noirs contre
carpates surtout avec les noirs en plus
c'est pas facile du tout c'était contre
est incroyable et contre karpov ces
contrées car la face elle non plus n'a
cédé qu'un peu on peut dire que karpov a
perdu aussi un peu tout seul on en fait
c'était quand même
nathan c'était la partie c'était la
grosse neige d'or chez veni scheveningen
où t'es sport fait jouer le plan tour 7
et 1 8
ouais je sais plus si c'est après cette
partie d'un bel été extraordinaire elle
était extraordinaire et une partie le
fou anatoly karpov n'a rien pu faire
il n'a rien pu faire kasparov a sorti un
plan qui n'a jamais été rejoué depuis
car incompréhensible personne n'en avait
vraiment saisine sens
voilà et oui notre réalisateur nous
commentent nos commentaires et ce qui
lui permet donc de sortir une phrase
digne de comment dire des piqûres
quand on ne s'en lasse pas on a plus
d'énergie
si si alors je ne sais pas ce que ça
veut dire
libre à vous d'interpréter les remarques
de yasny alors peut-être kasparov a le
syndrome 2 500 il faut que les poêles
puces pour qu'ils aient de l'énergie et
elle que et que peut-être la personne
qui le razz serait un espion envoyé par
kramnik à noter quand même que
l'organisation du tournoi a passé un
coup de bombe autour de l'échiquier
juste avant la partie pour éviter deux
noms reviennent des insectes teigneux
donc c'est du bees cdu ils ont passé des
boues nous dicte autres eh bien c'était
du bacon green bay john green qui a fait
son effet puisqu'il n'y a plus de
mouches aujourd'hui mais il y a quand
même garry kasparov qui est quand même
une grosse mouche et oui et qui
réfléchit comme un fou contre vladimir
kramnik avec les yeux
voilà une heure 23 contre une heure
cinquante quatre plans sur la pendule ya
vu bienvenue yannick effectivement c'est
là l'information importante de cette
début de cellules partie encore une fois
serait tenté de dire mme si incroyable
depuis le début depuis le début kasparov
ne s'en sort pas 37 minutes de réflexion
contre 5 minutes akram nick kasparov et
devant un cramique survoltée qui
pointent à chaque fois les problèmes du
jeu de kasparov qui est basé quand même
à 80% sur les ouvertures et sur
l'énergie et sur nrj
donc oui ici est nommé chronique laisse
kasparov s'épuiser dans cette ouverture
apparemment il connaît bien cette
position chronique il a l'air détendu il
l'a probablement bien analyser il a pour
le moment joué des parties
d'entraînement alors pour d'énergie
les joueurs ont droit aux femmes pendant
ce match on peut se poser la question je
pense que il dit en droit et ne s'en
prive pas en tout cas c'est sûr
garry kasparov lui a besoin de ça sinon
celle menée dans les situations
délicates et vladimir kramnik aussi
alors que kasparov a joué voilà ce
qu'est la 4c le plan que je savais bien
ri kasparov
c'est le plan du style et de soleure et
loi il joue au niveau de stéphane
laborde et on va montrer en troisième
position
voilà rien puisque joubert a été sport
alors c'est effectivement la seule
faiblesse noir dans le plan dans le
pardon à nos positions ce sont les cases
noires du côté dames puisque le les
coûts on va montrer les pions des pions
noirs sont tous sur place blanche et
donc le coût de castor calais à 4 a pour
but de mettre la pression sur les cases
noires voilà je pense que le but de ce
coup kelly à 4 et de sortir chronique de
sa préparation puisque c'est quand même
un coût très inattendue ça me coûterait
attendu qu'apple est très bon mais pas
la femme menace peut-être le coup fouet
3 à noter que dc comics va bien entendu
répondre non un entraînement vite mais
non et justement donc parce que sur tour
des huit qui aurait dame b3 tour d'élite
il va jouer quand hicks est sûre et sur
dan b3 il va gagner la partie il
instantanément en jouant le coût des
sept baies 5 pouces et gagne pas la
partie ça gagne l'option c4 et ça gagne
namias c'est vraiment ça gagne donc la
partie créé une pièce pourquoi puisque
après non non ça nous venons d'espagne m
thür l'option ces quatre hommes du raid
algérois dames 6 3 oui mais et alors
donne ses 3 ce n'est pas grave puisque
ici on peut jouer simplement fou cette
db5 n'a pas assez de mal car il mènerait
qu'à l'ère de gagner le qu'à madrid il
ya un an de 5
les cavaliers ans et 5 pouces être ici
tranquille et sûr hier voudra voir coup
que tu proposes et il faut 3 voilà bien
je pense que tu indiques pour jouer
simplement le cavalier
7 oui mais après que font les noirs eh
bien ils vont jouer petit roquet f6 ils
vont consolider leur position je verrais
bien un développement de la partie dans
ce sens là c'est possible à noter que ce
coup qui avait dit à 4 et moins ridicule
et qu'il y paraît mais bien sûr voilà la
position
garry kasparov bien 2,984 pour essayer
d'exploiter l'affaiblissement des six
c'est très intéressant
on sait en tout cas a priori c'est la
mêlée le coup c'est le seul coup qui
permet à chris pas d'espérer un semblant
d'initiative
il est alors dit qu'il s'est pas levée
d'un gary kasparov a énormément mais il
sait que cramique conomie fille lady
blood kasparov boude et week as for good
puisque il ne laissera ni de l'espace
jouit donc il va se plaindre à sa maman
kasparov il vous le dira mais kramnik me
laisse pas jouer
g [ __ ] passant pas grave ne me laisse
pas jouer je veux jouer aux échecs avec
mes règles avec les ouvertures et crying
ne laisse pas jouer j'en ai ras-le-bol
il est vraiment pas cool sauf à munich
et d'ailleurs je pense que jamais un
majeur la casse par robin je veux jouer
avec lui je peux plus je me plus joué
avec kramnik je me rentrer chez moi et
oui cas du tarp
il est très probable que la merde
kasparov à ce moment là à y voir les
parents de chroniques pour leur dire que
leur fils est pas sympa et qui
l'embêtent et qui l'embêtent ce petit
gars m et quand vous êtes le petit gars
y est que si ça continue elle va
s'énerver maman kasparov soit il faut
rappeler qu'à sport fait toujours suivi
par sa mère au moins pour les
championnats du monde c'est vrai est
toujours là et aujourd'hui elle est
encore là probablement dans les gradins
travnik est détendu quand même autre
amiga forcément prévu son coup d'oeil à
4 mais bon deuxième très fortement à
envisager dans cette position si on joue
cette position puisque c'est le seul
coup qui permet une éventuelle petite
initiative mais on les a doublées nord
pour jouer bcp 5 ha oui donc c'est
embêtant parce que ça libère le fuji de
cet hiver le projet de et chroniques
null null null au cas où il ya quatre
nuls bon eh bien aujourd'hui c'était
très court stéphane c'était très très
court et ce n'est pas forcément une
bonne nouvelle
incroyable garry kasparov capitule c'est
la capitulation de garry kasparov
complètement inattendu complètement
inattendue ça stéphane alors l'avenir de
l'as passage ça va être vite pompe est
aujourd'hui un numéro secoue la partie
le plus court du match très très
étonnant eh bien ça va reposer un peu
les serveurs de canal web
on avait bien besoin incroyable nul en
onze coups et ça c'est une surprise
en tout cas c'est une victoire pour
kramnik aujourd'hui avec les noirs il a
complètement mis à sac la préparation de
kasparov qui ne veut pas céder va plus
loin il est convaincu par la préparation
de kramnik victoire aux points encore
une fois de kramnik aujourd'hui
on va proposer nul aveu de faiblesse
encore de kasparov et ça c'est une ola
incroyable incroyable
kasparov ne peut plus jouer cramique le
muselle nul à 11 coups nul à 11 coups
aujourd'hui ça va être vite vu les
résumés vont être faciles à faire donc
là on va passer je sais pas si on va
vendre en la conférence de presse
normalement oui à une conférence de
presse de trois minutes
en fait très courte ses suivants nul à
11 coups bas de combat
kasparov ne réussit pas à prendre le
moindre avantage avec les blancs dans ce
match
ce que fait cramique dans ce match est
très fort on va peut-être passer
maintenant à notre interlude intendant
de démarrer la conférence de presse non
je sais pas on va attendre que là les
joueurs reviennent sur scène peut-être
nul à on secoue aujourd'hui
et bien voilà
pour la première fois depuis le début du
match on n'a pas droit
un débat sur l'échiquier nul et on
secoue par un corps mutuelle des joueurs
pour sur proposition de kasparov qui n'a
pas réussi à prendre le moindre avantage
avec les pièces blanches et c'est vrai
que chronique ne peut pas difficile
difficilement refuser la nulle puisque
les blancs proposant nul avec quand même
un tout petit très très léger avantage
délicat de refuser avec les noirs que
vont dire les joueurs la conférence de
presse probablement pas grand chose ça
va durer 2 minutes et je veux rentrer
chez eux se préparer pour les prochaines
parties incroyable que kasparov
ne veulent pas jouer chronique lui avec
les blancs même dans une position qui
semble égal arrive toujours à trouver
des plans pour attaquer kasparov lui
capitule s'il n'a pas obtenu un avantage
d'un l'ouverture c'est la grosse
différence entre les joueurs
kasparov et préparer dans les ouvertures
et joue exclusivement là dessus alors
que kramnik lui peut jouer toutes les
positions et ça se fait une grosse
différence
c'était la septième partie du match le
huitième chrono nique aura les blancs on
peut difficilement penser qu'il va
perdre et donc très probablement à la
mi-match chronique va mener et chronique
a atterri samedi a joué à fond la partie
puisque kasparov fatigué orale et blanc
dimanche et c'est plus difficile quand
on est fatigué de mener les blancs
puisque c'est les couleurs qui demande
le plus d'énergie et voilà les joueurs
pour la conférence de presse avec
kasparov qui tapote un peu sur la table
voilà c'est du corps du mal à répondre
si christophe il le sent tout de suite
il va avoir du mal pour nos questions on
va peut-être passer maintenant au son de
la salle difficulté enfin rodriguez
mc et canada et d'autres ministres des
mines et c'est un break mais fine
positionne au patrimoine sont maintenant
prises entre le faisait drôle les
problèmes sont tout sauf un spot de
winter games